talk about the friendly competition
between you gun and conway because i
feel like it's definitely there
like you guys are all you know
especially you and conway on the mc side
but like
quality of music all three of you guys
are out of here pray for paris one of
the best albums of the year
guns dropped three projects this year
you're about to drop your second
um conway dropped two pro but [ __ ] three
projects this year
yeah um but like is the competition
it seems very healthy and you guys are i
i always
whenever you guys drop some [ __ ] and
there's like those quintessential like
posse cuts like spurs three or whatever
it is like that's like my first record i
go
right right but like is it is it
competition and is it like has it ever
been to the point where you're like [ __ ]
like i got god on this record like i
feel like
when you have three artists on that
level of rapping
you know it's gotta it's gotta be like
steel sharpened steel yeah
no no is it is it competition i can't
look up here and say it's not
competition right
you know what i'm saying but trust me
it's healthy competition and it's not
like
devious competition right right right
right it's like
uh you know you know what con we're
going to do
so you want to and i mean so you want to
you want to bring your [ __ ] too
and we go to the we go to the shows
you know what i'm saying like what the
what the [ __ ] this [ __ ] be saying
he was like uh you know they get crazy
loud for west side gun [ __ ]
yeah you for what i'm saying they get
crazy loud so it's like he's like the
paul heyman of the crew yeah exactly
exactly so it's just like everybody
bring their own [ __ ] but man
when i hear the people loud at the shows
for uh
wes i want them to be loud for me and
i'm saying when i see the comments yo
conway drop the classic
i want my [ __ ] to be classic too of
course i mean so it's like it's that
type of [ __ ] and it's almost like you
know
just trying to keep up with each other
and [ __ ]